cardinals organization
the st louis community and baseball fans
everywhere were saddened to learn of the
passing of hall of famer
louis clark blue brock at the age of 81.
blue brock enjoyed 19 seasons in the
majors including parts of 16 years with
the cardinals
his uniform number 20 was retired by the
cardinals in 1979. he will be deeply
missed
and forever remembered
carlos is going to have a lot to say
about what happens down the stretch we
know how dominant he can be so the play
behind the runner here on three and two
donaldson he's off with his pitch
and he struck him out welcome back
carlos martinez the cardinals need you
today starting picture jose various it's
been up and down sometimes dominant
sometimes a little inconsistent coming
off a really good start against the
white sox
to left and rosario over a few steps to
end the inning the scoreless first in st
louis
his fastball is not in the middle he's
throwing strikes but not in the middle
and a fastball poke down the right field
line cave with a diving catch on the
line
jake cave closing again toward foul
territory makes a better catch than the
one he made yesterday
a terrific a terrific play by j cave i
didn't think he had any chance of
getting there he closed as dick said
just in the last three strides
full out dive fully extended
what's threatening here first and third
with one out and here is donaldson
here's the one two and hit high in the
air left field ball out of a chance
back goes the left fielder and it's gone
a three run homer for josh donaldson
and like that boy the twins take a three
to nothing lead
and donaldson boy it looked like he was
out in front
barely made it over
donaldson stay hot his third of the year
something off speed donaldson was
waiting on it looked like he was a
breaking ball and it hung
kind of backed up middle half in that's
almost the ball that nelson cruz got and
swung and missed on danny you said it
was supposed to be a slider but it acted
more like
and there's a line drive that's going to
be one hop into right field
as austin diehl
is going to make it all the way around
from second base what was the right
fielder i'm not sure why thomas didn't
even try
wow
he he fielded it and just casually just
said all right i'll concede this but i'm
shocked with two outs why he didn't even
try to come home i'm not sure
it's almost like he thought ostadio had
stopped around third base
and a fastball gets a swing of the miss
one down
breaking ball got him
in the dirt ostidio dug it out fifth
strikeout for berea change up is
is looking like a fastball
wow that might be the best inning he's
thrown this year goldsmith miller de
young the three four and five batters
for st louis they didn't have a chance
high and deep to right center field and
that ball is gone a home run into the
cardinal bullpen
cruz hitting his 14th of the year and
it's five to nothing nelson just said
you know if you're gonna keep pitching
me out there are you gonna keep throwing
me trying to throw breaking balls out
away from me keep the ball away i'm just
gonna have to go that way
because the ballpark is not big enough
out there to hold that
fastball out over the plate 75 pitches
so far and a dominant outing for barrios
breaking ball left upstairs got a swing
and a miss
two down that'll bring up thomas
comes back with a better one
eight strikeouts over five shutout
innings for jose barrios
tommy edmond
here's a 1-2 pitch
and edmond lifts a fly ball out to deep
right field it's at the wall goodbye
tommy edmond gets the cardinals on the
board
his third home run
a two-run homer for tommy edmond
and with that
the lead is cut to five to two
boy he battled for that home run he did
and he saw every pitch that barrios had
he fouled off a couple of fastballs five
to two uh twins
fastballs in the dirt and another a wild
pitch and the one scores is now five 5-3
well thank you very much twins they're
trying to get it to us aren't they they
are here's to know
he's going to hit a home run in this at
bat by the way
high fly to left
going back is o'neill and it is gone
it's a four-run lead one heck of a call
by you partner holy cow
looked like some kind of little change
up or
something so no was out in front of it
but got full extension he's just so
doggone strong
not a save situation for romo but he'd
still like to finish off the ball game
on this pitch
and he does three strikeouts
and he strikes out the side and the
twins win the opener 7-3 in